this
dumb [ __ ]
saying what he's saying and we're going
to get back to that marjorie taylor
green post because margie taylor green
says some damn [ __ ]
and she looks really desperate really
wormy uh worried i mean worried not
wormy worried that's why i meant um
on tucker carlson's show last night i
had that
so
where the [ __ ] is this video
there it is all right oh that no that's
it'll get me there
that's a video that artist michael made
[Music]
into cnn
to any spies here
so this is this is this is the same guy
that was at the stop the steel rally
where he announces jim i don't report
sex crimes jordan
this is the same [ __ ] i don't i
don't know what his name it doesn't
really matter what his name is but
that's the same it's the same
[ __ ]
same [ __ ]
so this this is all these right-wing
american taliban man they're trying to
they're trying to jump
jim up
no pun intended for jim jordan they're
trying to jim up uh uh
terrorism domestic terrorism that's what
they're trying to jam up here is
domestic terrorism so
today
i got a message for you
we
are coming for the school boards
you're going to be on the school board
really
we're coming for the city council
yeah he's going to be on city council
too
oh you're going to be the mayor the city
councilman and the school board member
oh he's going to be a sheriff too
we're even going for the ptas
nhoas
what the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] is this twit talking about you
hear me loud and clear
any
politician that supports vaccine
passports or mask mandates
we
will vote you
out yeah look at that gal in the super
woman's swimming suit what the [ __ ] is
this what are who are these people what
rocks did they crawl on underneath
[Music]
maybe i should put that on a [ __ ]
loop
[Music]
oh god
so that's some of the [ __ ] that we're
dealing with there
so
let's see what else what else do we have
so that's that's some of the yellow
kaida
americans
steph